[Music]
coach how are you this morning I'm doing
great dance I should have me on what's
all but a big deal going on in Houston
while y'all found there I think there's
a super bowl not sure rumor has it man
we hope will you watch the Super Bowl I
will I will especially when you have
guys like Ryan and Brady you know
there's going to be some exciting with
those two guys offensively so it should
be better than the commercials what
would you look at can you look at that
game as a fan or is it as a go
absolutely yeah no no I think you turn
off the coach when when you you know you
look at those two guys in particular the
way Brady has so much to play for in
this game you know he's done a great job
you know in the media and downplaying
the Roger Goodell fine but make no
mistake about it this is all about
winning this trophy and accepting it
from the commissioner so that's kind of
you know pretty exciting to watch that
could you teach what Brady does you know
I think a lot of the things that he's
done he's worked on his footwork in the
pocket I think that's all stuff of a
creation of what he's done in the
offseason to continue to do the things
he's doing in the NFL I mean I think
he's worked hard on his this capability
to stay alive in the pocket and yeah I
think a lot of that is teachable that
that he's really done himself talking to
Brian Kelly's national signing day to
the Notre Dame head coach what is the
scheduled today you know you started 6
30 in any starts to wait for the binding
letters to commend that defines exceeds
the young man to the University after
all the work the last year and a half
and getting these three student-athletes
to come to the University you know about
ninety percent of what's going to happen
but you know it still has to come
through you know you still have to get
paperwork
all done digitally it's changed
dramatically used to wait by the
fattening I'm waiting for those facets
commit now everything's done digitally
over the phone over the computer so
you're just waiting for those letters of
intent to command along the way you're
doing interviews you know your face
timing the recruits but I've done most
of my phone conversations with the 2018
and kind of you know in anticipation of
maybe getting them to come to Notre Dame
18 talking about this time next year you
might be this guy signing with Notre
Dame so most of my conversations been
with eight kings what happens if you got
somebody on the fence today how do you
convince them can you we go back to it
being a 40-year decision instead of a
Fourier decision when footballs out of
the equation and you've had a career
what are you going to do for the next 40
years Notre Dame degree is going to be
able to continue to work for your show
we go back to that and don't don't
select it for football select is for you
know the next 40 years when you're done
playing football week that's that's the
only way that we can really recruit and
stay competitive as power of our degree
for when you're done playing football
that steps I'll go to who broke your
heart on national signing day getting
names ah I don't know if anybody broke
our heart we're disappointed in a couple
of kids if we thought this was a better
fit form you know sometimes kids will
select based upon their heart over their
head we think it's just your selfish
decision in a sense that do what's right
for you for the rest of your life don't
make a decision because you got a bunch
of your buddies go into that school and
and weak like better guidance sometimes
an apparent saying look you got to do
what's right for you don't do what's
right because it feels right you know
and that that bothers me sometimes but
you know we're all parents and we try to
get the best guidance we can but I don't
know if it breaks your heart as much as
you disappointed that you know that they
could have made a better decision DeSean
Kaiser is an NFL quarterback
give us some thoughts first-round draft
pick you know I think I you know beauty
is in the eye of the beholder I think
he's got first round ability and
talented you know as you know Dan this
is so much about finding the right place
you know he's only played for two years
so you know he's got more work to do but
boy he's got talent he's got character
he's got leadership ability you know six
foot four is 240 pounds it's got strong
on he's got all the tools is he ready to
lead you to a superbowl probably not but
if he can get into the right situation I
think he definitely merits the first
round pick well good luck today coach
and hopefully we'll get out to another
Notre Dame game I can bring the boys to
the sidelines and we can call some place
like we did last year which was kind of
nice that you allowed us to call a few
place during the game at least I was
told did you know that we were calling
some play you did yeah yeah yeah you
were and we won because it yeah we
didn't win many ways I'm going to win a
lot more this year country just looking
on appreciate you having me on hi coach
thank you it's brian kelly notre dame
head coach coaches corner brought to you
by Continental Tire proud to be the
exclusive tire of the Dan Patrick show
maybe that was the problem that they
allowed us to Coulson place last year no
matter where you drive or what you drive
continental designs tires for what you
do for more information visit
Continental Tire com continental tire
for what you do the Dan Patrick show
weekday morning on audience
[Music]